It's Love In the City of Lights Tom
Holland and Zendaya spotted strolling in
Paris hand in hand yeah I know I know
here are the lovebirds snapped touring
the Louvre and if you look real close
that right there that is some
hand-holding people I am sweating Tom
looked casual Chic rocking a black and
white striped long-sleeved sweater while
the Euphoria star was all kinds of gorge
with her hair pulled back glasses a
light blue shirt dress and a crossbody
bag well I wanted something that was
casual and cool of course this trip to
the city of love is just the latest
getaway for the duo I just feel very
lucky
um that's really all I always say it the
pairs popped up in Boston and New York
in recent months and yes lots of hand
holding there too the duo went public
with their love last year after years of
playing koi about their relationship
having found that it's hard to date in
Hollywood so yeah it's such a young age
of course romance rumors first sparked
on the Spider-Man press tour in 2017.
this happens all the time and of course
you know we we expected it I mean it's
it's um it comes with the territory it
comes with the job so it's all good fast
forward a few years later and Tom
confirmed tea and Zendaya they're a
thing and then we got this Swoon worthy
moment
just showed up
down
that's her no no that's I want to see
what she has on can we watch is she
gonna walk down here
it's her let's watch
[Applause]
oh she's going in she's going in she's
going in she's going okay that's
definitely isn't there yeah safe to say
the love is more than neutral I think
it's great to have that support and and
that love around you because you need
that you know this isn't an easy easy
job so it's good to have
that to to free you up from it every now
and then now Tom was noticeably absent
from the Emmys last month where Z took
home her second trophy for her starring
role on Euphoria but as she told E.T
backstage he was there in spirit okay
you didn't shout out to Tom was that nut
no no
no no he's part of my loved ones see
there you go
[Music]
thank you